Ukraine is desperately trying to restore
electricity as temperatures drop across
the country and Russia escalates its
missile attack on Ukraine's energy
infrastructure and power grid at least
15 people including one child were
killed after Russia launched a barrage
of missiles in Kirsten the attack on the
city that Ukrainian forces recaptured
earlier this month is the deadliest in
recent days Chris livesay has the latest
well the attacks across Ukraine may seem
like isolated incidents but they're part
of a much bigger Russian plot to freeze
the country into submission
Ukrainian Winters are never easy
especially during a war with Russia's
Relentless attacks on the power grid the
government says it only has half of the
energy it needs turning the light so dim
it's been reduced to a dark patch on the
globe at night as these NASA images from
space show Russia is hoping this will
slow Ukraine's momentum on the
battlefield says Keith Mayer Vitale
kalichko the Russians doesn't have
success in Battlefield and they right
now
I tried to attack and destroy the Civil
population and that sounds like
terrorism
it's not South Easter eggs the U.S
estimates more than 100 000 Russian
troops have been killed so far ahead of
Russian Mother's Day Vladimir Putin held
a meeting with women the Kremlin said
are mothers of soldiers he told them
death on the battlefield gives their
lives meaning but at times it was
strange
while in Ukraine's Capital Kiev
residents huddle into tents to stay warm
and charge their batteries like video
game designer Constantine so this is
hard times but I don't think that it's a
lot it will last forever it will pass
and we will win definitely no doubt
and he's not alone according to polling
more than 90 percent of ukrainians say
they're willing to put up with these
conditions for two even three more years
so long as Ukrainian forces continue to
hold back Russia Dana
all right Chris thank you very much